I'm thrilled to be talking to you by
this high-tech method of all humans
who've ever lived the overwhelming
majority would have found what we're
doing here incomprehensible unbelievable
because for thousands of centuries in
the dark time before the Scientific
Revolution and the Enlightenment people
had low expectations for their lives for
their descendants lives typically they
expected nothing significantly new or
better to be achieved ever this
pessimism famously appears in the Bible
in one of the few biblical passages with
a named author
it's called qohelet he's an enigmatic
chap he wrote what has been is what will
be and what has been done is what will
be done there is nothing new Under the
Sun is there something of which it is
said look this is new now that thing was
already done in the ages that came
before us the qohelet was describing a
world without novelty by novelty I mean
something new in qohelet sense not
merely something that's changed but a
significant change with lasting effects
where people really would say look this
is new and preferably good so purely
random changes aren't novelty okay
Heraclitus did say a man can't step in
the same river twice because it's not
the same river he's not the same man but
if the river is changing randomly it
really is the same river in contrast if
an idea in a mind spreads to other minds
and changes lives for
generations that is novelty human life
without novelty is life without
creativity without progress it's a
static society a zero-sum game that was
the living hell in which qohelet lived
like everyone until a few centuries ago
it was hell because for humans suffering
is intimately related to statistica's
statistic all sources of suffering
famine pandemics incoming asteroids and
things like war and slavery hurt people
only until we have created the knowledge
to prevent them there's a story in
Somerset Maugham zhn Avila fumin bondage
about an ancient sage who summarizes the
entire history of mankind as he was born
he suffered and he died and it goes on
life was insignificant and death without
consequence
and indeed the overwhelming majority of
humans who've ever lived had lives of
suffering and grueling labor before
dying young and in agony and yes in most
generations nothing had any novel
consequence for subsequent generations
nevertheless when ancient people tried
to explain their condition they
typically did so in grandiose cosmic
terms which was the right thing to do as
it turns out even though their actual
explanations that their myths were
largely false some tried to explain the
grimness and monotony of their world in
terms of an endless cosmic war between
good and evil in which humans were the
battleground which neatly explained why
their own
Ariane's was full of suffering and why
progress never happened but it wasn't
true amazingly enough all their conflict
and suffering were just due to the way
they processed ideas being satisfied
with Dogma and just so stories rather
than criticizing them and trying to
guess better explanations of the world
and of their own condition 20th century
physics did create better explanations
but still in terms of a cosmic war this
time the combatants were order and chaos
or entropy that story does allow for
hope for the future but in another way
it's even bleaker than the ancient myths
because the villain entropy is
preordained to have the final victory
when the inexorable laws of
thermodynamics
shut down all novelty with the so called
heat death of the universe currently
there's a story of a local battle in
that war between sustainability which is
order and wastefulness which is chaos
that's the contemporary take on good and
evil often with the added twist that
humans are the evil so we shouldn't even
try to win and recently there have been
tales of another cosmic war between
gravity which collapses the universe and
dark energy which finally shreds it so
this time whichever of those cosmic
forces wins we lose all those
pessimistic accounts of the human
condition contains some truth but as
prophecies they're all misleading and
all for the same reason none of them
portrays humans as what we really are as
Jacob Bronowski said man is not a figure
in the landscape here's the
shaper of the landscape in other words
humans are not playthings of cosmic
forces we are users of cosmic forces
I'll say more about that in a moment but
first while sorts of thing create
novelty well the beginning of the
universe surely did the Big Bang nearly
14 billion years ago created space time
and energy everything physical and then
immediately what I call the first era of
novelty with the first atom the first
star the first black hole the first
galaxy but then at some point novelty
vanished from the universe perhaps from
as early as 12 or 13 billion years ago
right up to the present day there's
never been any new kind of astronomical
object there's only been what I call the
great monotony so qohelet was
accidentally even more right about the
universe beyond the Sun then he was
about Under the Sun so long as the great
monotony lasts what has been out there
really is what will be and there is
nothing out there of which you can truly
be said look this is new nevertheless at
some point during the great monotony
there was an event inconsequential at
the time and even billions of years
later it had affected nothing beyond its
home planet yet eventually it could
cause cosmically momentous novelty that
event was the origin of life creating
the first genetic knowledge coding for
Biological adaptations coding for
novelty on earth it utterly transformed
the surface genes in the DNA of
single-celled organisms put oxygen in
the air
extracted co2 put chalk and iron ore
into the ground
hardly a cubic inch of the surface to
some depth has remained unaffected by
those genes the earth became if not a
novel place on the cosmic scale
certainly a weird one just as an example
beyond Earth only a few hundred
different chemical substances have been
detected presumably there are some more
in lifeless locations but on earth
evolution created billions of different
chemicals then the first plants animals
and then in some ancestor species of
ours explanatory knowledge for the first
time in the universe for all we know
explanatory knowledge is the defining
adaptation of our species it differs
from the non explanatory knowledge in
DNA for instance by being universal that
is to say whatever can be understood can
be understood through explanatory
knowledge and more any physical process
can be controlled by such knowledge
limited only by the laws of physics and
so explanatory knowledge too has begun
to transform the Earth's surface and
soon the earth will become the only
known object in the universe that turns
aside incoming asteroids instead of
attracting them qohelet was
understandably misled by the painful
slowness of progress in his day novelty
in human life was still too rare to
gradual to be noticed in one generation
and in the biosphere the evolution of
novel species was even slower but both
things were happening now why is there a
great monotony in the universe at large
and what makes our planet
bark that trend well the universe at
large is relatively simple stars are so
simple that we can predict their
behavior billions of years into the
future and retro dict how they formed
billions of years ago so why is the
universe simple basically it's because
big massive powerful things strongly
affect lesser things and not vice-versa
I call that the hierarchy rule for
example when a comet hits the Sun the
Sun carries on just as before but the
comet is vaporized for the same reason
big things are not much affected by
small parts of themselves ie by details
which means that their overall behavior
is simple and since nothing very new can
happen to things that remain simple the
hierarchy rule by causing large-scale
simplicity has caused the great monotony
but the saving grace is the hierarchy
rule is not a law of nature it just
happens to have held so far in the
universe except here in our biosphere
molecule sized objects genes control
vastly disproportionate resources the
first genes for photosynthesis by
causing their own proliferation and then
transforming the surface of the planet
have violated or reversed the hierarchy
rule by the mind-blowing factor of 10 to
the power 40 explanatory knowledge is
potentially far more powerful because of
universality and more rapidly created
when human knowledge has achieved a
factor 10 to the 40 it will pretty much
control the entire galaxy and we'll be
looking beyond so humans and any other
explanation
Gators who may exist out there are the
ultimate agents of novelty for the
universe we're the reason and the means
by which novelty and creativity
knowledge progress can have objective
large-scale physical effects from the
human perspective the only alternative
to that living hell of static societies
is continual creation of new ideas
behaviors new kinds of objects this
robot will soon be obsolete because of
new explanatory knowledge progress but
from the cosmic perspective explanatory
knowledge is the Nemesis of the
hierarchy rule it's the destroyer of the
great monotony so it's the creator of
the next cosmological era the
Anthropocene if one can speak of a
cosmic war it's not the one portrayed in
those pessimistic stories it's a war
between monotony and novelty between
stasis and creativity and in this war
our side is not destined to lose if we
choose to apply our unique capacity to
create explanatory knowledge we could
win thanks
[Applause]